Disney just dropped the first music
video from descendants three and the new
VK costumes are epic keep watching for a
breakdown of Mao and the gangs brand-new
outfits on May 31st 2019 Disney Channel
dropped the good to be bad music video
this is the first song that we have
heard from the new dissonance movie and
it's amazing we always love the musical
numbers that happen on the Isle of the
Lost
in this video we get to see now evj and
Carlos return to their home on the Isle
its VK day and they are selecting for
new students to attend art on crack and
it looks like everyone on the Isle is
super pumped to see them the song is
awesome the dancing was epic but did you
see all the new costumes let's dive in
and take a look at the V Ches new and
amazing outfits Evie the daughter of the
Evil Queen from Snow White has got it
all Evie is super sweet super smart and
a total style Queen Evie might have the
best sense of fashion of anyone on the
Isle or an Oregon when I look at you all
I can think of this fake fur she's got a
real knack for fashion design so it's no
surprise that her new outfit is on fire
she is ready to slay when she comes back
to recruit new V Ches
Evie is still rocking her long blue hair
with her tiara she wants everyone to
know she is a princess she is vac and
leather in this music video she wears a
long-sleeve leather jacket and we just
loved the way it fastens with those
buckles
she looks so tough the blue color is a
lot more toned down than her usual
bright colors it's paired with some
brown and red on her leather pants we
also totally dig the flared miniskirts
and just take a look at those
high-heeled boots seriously where can we
get a pair of those J the athletic
flirty son of Jafar has a pretty unique
style it hasn't changed much since the
first movie and he still manages to look
like a tough VK even when he is in
auradon it's called stealing it's like
it's free good to be bad J is still seen
wearing his red beanie over his long
dark hair we're glad because he just
wouldn't look like J without it he's
also wearing a sleeveless leather vest
it's got several shades of red black and
yellow this is pretty typical for J but
the colors are a lot more muted and
earthy he's also wearing red pants with
his outfit to match his beanie J
definitely still looks the part of a V K
but we know better he is such a good guy
his new outfit manages to look really
athletic he is the captain of the swords
and shields team and a star tour knee
player after all dizzy dizzy Jermaine
was introduced in descendants - she is
the daughter of Drizella Jermaine one of
Cinderella's wicked stepsisters but the
only thing wicked about dizzy is her
sense of style dizzy is a super talented
hairstylist Evie and mal get their hair
done by this young VK it was hinted in
descendants - that she would get a
chance to go to our don we love you to
join us - auradon prep but in the new
music video she's still on the Isle we
first see dizzy sweeping up hair she is
so pumped to see Evie dizzy is wearing a
super cute patchwork dress it's got a
bit of a ruffle at the bottom that is so
dizzy she's kind of got some Cinderella
vibes going on but she manages to make
it look super cute her hair is down
instead of in pigtails and she has a hat
that perfectly matches her dress way to
coordinate dizzy we can't wait to see
how her style evolves when she gets to
auradon
Celia Celia is a new character in
descendants three and we have been so
pumped to see her in action
she is the daughter of dr. facile ear
the voodoo villain from The Princess and
the Frog it sure looks like she has a
good relationship with mal mal seeks our
out on her own and Celia looks excited
to see her Celia is dressed so adorably
she tells fortunes and she totally looks
the part she is wearing a long showman
style jacket it's got a long tail but
this isn't your typical Black Tie tuxedo
it's mostly blue with lots of other
different colors mixed in the patterns
on this jacket are amazing we just love
all the detail the costume designers
threw in Celia also has a pink bow tie
she tops off her look with a tiny top
hat and purple flower it's flashy and
fierce you can definitely see that her
dad influenced her style but she is
rocking her own unique vibe
Carlos Carlos's costume might have
undergone the most change since the
first movie and it really shows just how
much the character has grown Cruella de
Vil son has always worn a combination of
red black and white but in the new movie
white is the main colour it shows us
just how good and pure of a character he
is and we love seeing how much
confidence he has now Carlos also looks
less like a biker and more grunge and he
totally pulls it off his black and white
jacket is a mix of leather and denim
it's got a hood on it like the classic
90s style he pairs this with matching
pants that look away comfier than J's
Carlos is also rocking a new hairstyle
in this movie he's grown out his hair
some and is wearing it loose
he's definitely grown up a lot since the
first Descendants film now no one rocks
the leather VK look like mal mal has
definitely come into her own since the
first movie and her outfit shows off
just how confident and powerful she is
with her magical powers Mouse hair is a
much darker purple than the last movie
and it looks so good she's still rocking
a purple and green outfit but take a
look at the details on it she is wearing
a long leather jacket the shoulders have
some Flair that look almost like dragon
scales we know mal has the ability to
become a dragon just like her mom
Maleficent but instead of mal trying to
fight that side of her this costume
shows that she has embraced it
we are also totally digging the bottom
of the jacket it's got a jagged hemline
it's longer than her past jackets it's
almost the length of us
skirt it's just girly enough to be now
she pairs this outfit with purple and
green leather pants and check out those
boots they're absolutely wicked so whose
new look is your favorite let us know in
the comments that's a wrap give this
video a big thumbs up and hit that
subscribe button thanks for watching the
things see you next time
[Music]